five remarkably gifted men were
nominated as actors in a leading role
here they are
Warren Beatty in Bugsy's Robert DeNiro
in Cape Fear Anthony Hopkins in the
Silence of the land Nick Nolte in the
Prince of tides
Robin Williams in the Fisher King
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Anthony Hopkins
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
my god I can't believe it I this is
really unexpected I it's a great honor
to be especially with such great actors
like Nick Nolte and Warren Beatty and
Robin Williams Robert DeNiro first of
all I just before I say I want to say
hello to my mother she's in Wales
watching this on television with even
Jean and Jill and Tony
my father died 11 years ago tonight so
maybe he had something to do with this
as well right no but I want to say thank
you to the Academy for your tremendous
generosity to my friend Bob Palmer my
friend publicist my dear beloved wife
Jenny and I have many people to thank
here in Los Angeles who over the years
have given me tremendous support without
whose help I wouldn't be here I know and
I am greatly honored and tremendously
moved and I god bless you all thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]